premier temps qu'à ses premières scènes
très très prenant c'était un mariage
mariage lui est dans le bon sens du
terme avec toute la la chaleur que ça
signifie c'est pas beau de mentir
voilà on n'a pas de mémoire dont elle
fait d'abord le petit jardin tête les
petits trucs comme ça
clichy est à oublier gauguin pas bien je
viens de te souvenir
waouh première paye sans fin en passant
l'époque donc c'était 13500 comprends
c'est bien payé parce que tu foutais de
coursiers crédit lyonnais
descendez les marches à monter mais la
plupart dont j à l'époque donc j'étais
sûr pays premier disque me souviens pas
très bien mais je crois à nos fins
promis ce qui est important c'est bien
sûr moulin à vent ça doit être des
constantes et une
bécaud aznavour des gens comme ça cette
fois mais n'a pas obtenu les chanteurs
français qui faisait bouger les choses
allaient la première communion pas lui
dit le sans crainte mais j'étais un des
premiers communiants à nova avec une
photo merveilleuse aux gens un peu
iglesias comme ça j'étais présent contre
jose déjà pas mal dans les facs
on y voit ses avocats marrons qui ça
semble ce texte regroupe les choses
c'est un premier mariage somptueux
j'imagine qu'on s'était c'est bojan ce
pari j'avais 18 19 ans et c'était le
contraire
exane est passé quand on se marie c'est
pour l'alignement non mais on va confier
à 30 tonnes première école de grains et
whisky donc c'est marrant on tombe
toujours aux mêmes usages
il n'avait pas 17 ans d'actes 1er mai je
crois que le premier whisky se doit de
leur part ils choisissaient temps gfr ce
pétard jeudi avec jean marie périer des
gens n'a été fait chez macho man à new
york à manhattan dans un squat
d'appartements louis xiii première ligne
allait bien après le puits où ça se sait
des choses qui sont faits pour
travailler des tares n'est pas fait pour
travailler sans je pense pas
tu permets que je sorte mes chances
ratées de l'attitude abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu